North Korea's detention of another
American citizen is adding to the
tensions between the u.s. and North
Korea Kim sang deuk also known as Tony
Kim was taken into custody Saturday the
byung-hyun International Airport
president Trump spoke by phone last
night with Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a and Chinese President Xi
Jinping about North Korea's nuclear
program Chinese media says she told
President Trump that he hoped all
parties will exercise restraint Adriana
Diaz is in Beijing with the latest on
the escalating tensions with North Korea
Adriana good morning good morning
Tony Kim's attention was confirmed by
the elite North Korean University where
he taught well the circumstances around
his detention remain unclear it
complicates an increasingly tense
relationship between the u.s. and North
Korea at a time when both sides are open
to military action with the USS Carl
Vinson heading to the Korean Peninsula
North Korea continues its show of
defiance a statement from the Pyongyang
University of Science and Technology
confirmed that Tony Kim had been
detained as he was about to leave the
country after spending several weeks
teaching at the school Kim is the third
American currently being held in North
Korea in 2016 otto warmbier then a 21
year olds University of Virginia student
was sentenced to 15 years of hard labor
after he allegedly stole a political
banner from a Pyongyang hotel a few
months later came dong Cho a naturalized
US citizen was sentenced to 10 years for
espionage this is typical North Korean
at a time when there's so much tension
former New Mexico Governor Bill
Richardson has negotiated prisoner
releases from North Korea they used
these detainees from the United States
as bargaining chips they always want
something in return
since the arrest the regime has
continued its war of words threatening
Australia with a nuclear attack for its
alliance with the United States and on
Sunday North Korean state media took aim
at the u.s. writing our revolutionary
forces are combat ready
to think a u.s. nuclear-powered aircraft
carrier with a single strike this may be
a path forward some of these prisoner
releases have led to at least a dialogue
with North Korea and that's a step
forward with no direct diplomatic ties
the u.s. is working with the Swedish
embassy in North Korea on Kim's case he
was with his wife when he was detained
she was it and is believed to still be
in North Korea